this episode of shots of awe is brought
to you by the Toyota Prius let's lead
the way
so I'm fascinated by the extent to which
our environment molds and shapes us how
what is without becomes within and so I
recently discovered this this term
called ontological designing which is
essentially the notion that everything
that we design is designing us back we
we from inside out we are designed by
that which we have designed so there's
this circularity this meaning making
circle this hermeneutic circle you know
we're like the arrow burrows you know
we're like the snake eating its own tail
we're like Esther's hands you know the
hand that's drawing the hand that is
drawing it you know these feedback loops
are where mind emerges and it turns out
that mind that really subjectivity who
we are you know as life beings in the
world exists in that feedback loop
emerges in that feedback loop you know
we learn language but then that language
molds our personalities and then our
molded personalities use language to
speak out and then that which we speak
and read and turn changes us and there's
this circularity right so Marshall
McLuhan use to talk about the role of
Technology in this space in this context
so we build the tools but then those
tools build us we build these
smartphones and then these smartphones
change how we think and they change our
behavior that's why that's why they used
to say that the PC the computer was the
LSD of the 90s because the computer
revolution literalized the dream of
expanding our minds through the use of
our feedback with these tools in these
computers Steven Johnson takes it
further he talks about architecture he
says our thoughts shape our spaces we
designed the world but those spaces
return the favor so we build these
cathedrals and then those cathedrals
build cathedrals inside our minds
essentially you know we we mirror the
environment that we create so what is
our responsibility then
build the cities of the 21st century the
city planners the the urban designers
how do we make better systems thinking
better feedback loops to kind of like
upgrade how we function in the world you
know to upgrade mankind to understand
the city as an organism and as Geoffrey
West says from the Santa Fe Institute
you know cities are like organisms
alleys are like capillaries and so
understanding these feedback loops
observing these feedback loops upgrading
these feedback loops allows us to raise
the stage in which we unfold and that's
why ontological designing is an
important idea
you